well I held my excitement for you season
4 about as well as Kate and Joe
disposing of a body
[Music]
yes America's favorite toxic stalker is
taking on Europe and I've never been
more excited you are wrong
softer Joe please my mom watches these
videos I was ready to piss on your face
to prove I'm enough for you
why you season 4 part 1 is a wild who
done it and in this video we'll be going
over the killer what to expect in part
two and how Joe's class assignments hint
at where the story could be going and
you'll want to stick around to the end
of the video as I have a theory that's
going to blow your mind that Rhys
Montrose isn't who we think he is now as
of the time of this writing I've only
seen episodes one to five so any of my
theories involving part 2 are just that
I've also left time stamps below to the
topics I'll be covering if you want to
skip ahead that being said I will be
covering part two so make sure you're
subscribed so you're notified as soon as
that comes out in order to understand
how they eat the rich killer came into
Joe's orbit we have to examine how Joe
Goldberg became Professor Jonathan Moore
this is really important as it ties into
what might happen in part two at the end
of season 3 Joe successfully framed the
love for several of the murders in Madre
Linda faked his own death and left his
son Henry with a Charming gay couple
he'll call leaving his son the hardest
thing he's ever done however over the
course of the next five episodes he
rarely if ever mentions him I wouldn't
be surprised if Joe cares more about his
obsession Marion than he does about his
own son as I'll prove later on Joe wants
to become a better person and redeem
himself not for the sake of his son but
to win Marion back the last we saw of
Joe he was hanging out in Paris he knew
that's where Marion was likely headed
after the events of season three so he
stalked every artist haunt in the
country knowing she was an artist in
search of her ultimately finding one of
her paintings which led him to an art
show in England Joe is so blind to the
fact that Marion thinks he's a crazy
person he chases her down and vows to
prove to her that she's wrong about him
you're wrong about me you know what I
want to prove it to you I think this is
the most important line in the first
five episodes It's Joe's motivation for
the entire season to prove to Marion
that he isn't the monster she makes him
out to be and to her surprise as he lets
her go this is where Joe begins his
transformation into Jonathan Moore while
stalking Mary and Joe is approached by a
man named Elliot tannenberg essentially
a Hitman hired by love Quinn's father to
track Joe down and kill him but lucky
for Joe Elliott is tired of the Hitman
business and offers a solution that may
be beneficial for both him and Joe if
Joe Promises to Keep a low profile he'll
give him a new Alias a new chance at
life Elliot gets to keep the money Joe
gets to keep his life and Love's father
can sleep knowing his daughter's
murderer is six feet under it's win-win
John it could be your test too you know
too
make some different choices but there's
one catch Maria knows Joe is still alive
thus Joe is tasked with killing her to
tie up this loose end but as we find out
in the show he doesn't go through with
it instead stealing her locket to prove
to Elliot he finished the job in fact he
keeps this locket with him even when he
started his new life he's still obsessed
with her whether he admits it or not as
I'll get to in my part 2 Theory section
I don't think we're done with Marion
just yet so Joe takes up this new Alias
of Jonathan Moore a man whose background
allows Joe to get any job he wants and
what better job for Joe than a
literature Professor it's his job that
puts him in close contact with Malcolm
the Eat the Rich Killers first victim by
the end of episode 5 we learn the Eat
the Rich Killer's identity a man who
might be the next mayor of London Rhys
Montrose we first meet him in episode 1
where Joe finds him the only one he can
stomach at a socialite party held at
Adam Pratt's sundry house the first clue
he's the Killer is that he's is the only
one in this Elite group who knew the
pain of growing up in a society that
looked down on the poor everyone in this
friend group is downright ghastly when
it comes to treating the disenfranchised
in fact Adam here has a fetish where he
can only get off if servants piss on him
Rhys unlike the others who were born
with a silver spoon grew up in extreme
poverty and was raised by an unstable
single mother his life was a mess until
he found out he was the son of a Duke
went to Oxford where he met these fine
folks and went on to write his
critically acclaimed Memoir a good man
in a cruel world which we can see here
in the promotional material as well as a
book Nadia enjoys in episode 2 Nadia
states that all Motors in a whodunit
boiled down to three things two all
motives always boil down to six money or
Revenge so it appears Rhys falls into
the Revenge category wanting to get back
for his [__] childhood his friends don't
even care that the common folk are
struggling they don't see what the world
Burns it's after Reese leaves his
conversation that a Joe loses his phone
and B appears increasingly intoxicated
although it's left up to the viewer
whether or not he was slip something or
just drank too much while Reese had his
phone he installed an app called Evan s
which allowed him to communicate with
Joe anonymously now it's also possible
that Reese has a network of accomplices
aiding him in his plan but I'm not a
hundred percent sold on this Theory just
yet it would after all explain how Rhys
who's supposed to be an extremely busy
man is in so many places at a time maybe
it was one of his accomplices who
drugged Joe took his phone or dropped
Malcolm's ring in his jacket in episode
3. what about gemma's death in episode 4
did Rhys killer then just hide for
several hours until he reveals himself
later on there's just a lot of weird
stuff here that isn't adding up we get
some more clues with the murder of Simon
Sue check out the murderer's pants
they're the same as the waiters catering
the event and definitely not what Reese
was wearing now it's also possible he
took one of these uniforms to commit the
murder the murderer wore black shoes
while the catering staff all wore white
Rhys also wears black shoes but it's too
difficult to confirm if they're a match
in episode 5 we'll see him donning these
leather gloves which may also be the
same leather gloves used to kill Simon I
just wanted to throw this Theory out
there for you to keep in mind while
watching part two Reese is also the only
character that we the viewer sees give a
eulogy at Simon's funeral and when he
starts talking about hiding our true
identities under Mass I had red flags
going off like crazy but we all wear
different masks depending
and of course parts of us we can't bear
to show to anyone it isn't until episode
5 that Reese reveals himself as the Eat
the Rich killer having to save Joe from
being killed by a drug-fueled rolled but
this leaves so many questions why taunt
Joe why simultaneously try to frame him
for murder only to save him from Death
then moments later burn him alive
beneath the halls of borehole
blacksworth I think this has something
to do with Edgar Allan Poe's The Man of
the crowd a short story that is brought
up in Joe's class in episode 3. it tells
of a narrator who follows a man
throughout crowded London slowly
becoming obsessed with him making up his
own theories of what this man has done
and who he is in this metaphor Rhys is
the narrator and Joe is the old man Rhys
like the narrator in the story follows
Joel around and makes assumptions about
his character this leads to him becoming
more and more obsessed later digging
into his past as we see with these
articles that he leaves pin to his wall
and part of this Obsession stems from
Rhys believing Joe is like him the
feeling that he's found someone and is
no longer alone in fact the epigraph of
the man of the crowd States quote this
great Misfortune of not being able to be
alone both Rhys and Joe can't stand
being alone they share a similar
upbringing they're both killers and both
compulsively obsessive Rhys wants to
join with Joe as partners in a
quote-unquote project just like Joe
wants to be partners with those he
obsesses over so when Reese comes back
and finds Joe hasn't killed rolled like
he asked he thinks he's gotten Joe all
wrong he lights the place on fire and if
Joe should survive they can revisit this
topic in London expect this in part two
now I have two absolutely insane
theories I want to throw out there what
if Reese is Joe's half-brother Jakey the
last we saw of Jakey was when he was a
little boy with Joe's mentally unstable
mother it's Bonkers but could be a
really fun twist if the writers pull it
off second what if Reese is one of the
forgotten children of borehole
blacksworth making him a relative of
Phoebe when he reveals himself to Joe he
tells him he's done research on the
borehaul blacks worth stating you'll
find family members who disappeared
children who
they didn't fit the decor what if Reese
was one of these children it would give
him an even deeper personal motivation
for getting back at the rich and Phoebe
and her friends in particular all these
theories hinge on the ambiguity of
Reese's upbringing leaving lots of
opportunity to further flesh out his
character but doesn't he have a memoir
that outlines his childhood well he told
Joe that parts of his book were a lie so
he can't take anything in his Memoir at
face value this leads to theories for
part two again I have not seen the
episodes so feel free to laugh at me
when I'm proven completely wrong Reese
obviously has a much bigger plan here as
he launches his candidacy for mayor of
London he states that he'll be a
champion of the poor but this position
may also help him cover up even greater
crimes and give him access to more and
more influential people if episodes one
to five were finding out who the killer
was expect episode 6 to 10 to revolve
around Joe stopping him but I think the
biggest thing part 2 will delve into is
this idea of redemption can Joe prove to
Marion that he is redeemed in episode 1
Joe has his class read Ted Chang's hell
is the absence of God a story about a
man desperately trying to get into
heaven to reunite with his love Joe is
desperately trying to reunite with
Marion but can't in his mind unless he
achieves this Redemption much like the
character in Chang's were later in
episode 1 Joe will ask Rhys if he thinks
Redemption is possible I think yes
as long as they commit to never run from
themselves
face it all no matter what but how does
one achieve Redemption Fang isn't
actually saying the highest Redemption
is doing good he's saying it's just love
a truly selfless act for love may be
what is required for Joe to achieve this
Redemption just how that ties into
stopping Reese and potentially proving
to Mary and she's wrong about him
remains to be seen another big wild card
here is Kate's Father Tom Lockwood
Apparently one of the world's richest
and powerful men I can't help but feel
there's more to this hell even though
the man's been estranged from his
daughter since she was 20 he still pays
for round-the-clock security for her
although it's ambiguous whether this is
for her safety or to keep tabs on her
having this evil capitalist and Rhys who
hates the elite I can't help but think
they'll come into conflict now I've
outlined a bunch of wild theories and
what we might expect for part two but
what do you think I want to hear all
your thoughts and theories in the
comments below be sure to drop a like
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on Twitter and Instagram at thinkstory
YT until next time remember member you
are wrong my dick's never been softer